This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
This week we had planned originally on doing a show that would be kind of light and funny. But with the news on Tuesday, we all lost heart for that, and set about looking for material that would, in some way, reflect and illuminate what I think most of us are feeling in the wake of the destruction at the World Trade Center and the Pentagon. We're going to have a show of news stories on these things for you next week, hopefully. Until then, we put together this hour of stories in which people reflect on loss, and try to make sense of things that don't exactly make sense.
本周，我们原计划制作一期轻松有趣的节目。但周二的新闻出来后，我们都失去了兴致，转而寻找一些能以某种方式反映并启发我们内心感受的素材——我想大多数人在世界贸易中心和五角大楼遭受破坏后都有同样的感受。希望下周我们能为您带来一期关于这些事件的新闻报道。在此之前，我们整理了这一个小时的节目，讲述人们如何反思失去，并试图去理解那些根本无法理解的事情。
For instance, this story. When Mark was 15, his father was shot and killed, and Mark reacted like a 15-year-old. He went up to each of his relatives-- to anybody who would listen, actually-- and he declared that someday when he grew up he would become a pro football player, and he would find the man who shot his father.
例如这个故事。马克15岁时，他的父亲被枪杀，马克的反应像个15岁的孩子。他走到每一位亲戚面前——其实是任何愿意听的人面前——宣称等他长大后，他要成为一名职业足球运动员，并要找出那个杀害他父亲的人。
It's really-- when I look back at that kid, that 15-year-old kid making that promise, it's pathetic in a way.
真的——当我回顾那个孩子，那个许下诺言的15岁少年时，觉得这在某种程度上很可悲。
Well, it's such a particular vision of what a pro football player is. Which is to say, as a kid you're trying to conjure the notion of somebody who's very powerful, but also pure somehow.
嗯，对于职业足球运动员的认知，那是一种很独特的看法。也就是说，作为一个孩子，你试图勾勒出一个既非常强大，又在某种程度上很纯粹的人的形象。
Yes. And I remember even then some friends saying, now Mark, pro football is kind of a lofty goal. Maybe high school football. Years later, when I reflected back on that, I thought, jeez, the kid's dad just was killed. Why disabuse him of some vision he's got?
是的。我记得那时甚至还有朋友说，马克啊，职业足球是个很高的目标。也许高中足球还行。多年后，当我反思这件事时，我想，天哪，这孩子的父亲刚刚被杀。为什么要去戳破他心中的某种憧憬呢？
Mark's dad was a bar owner in Fresno, California. Two men came into the bar, played a game of pool, ordered two beers, then came into the back room and shot him. They didn't take any money. It was a gangland-style hit. And there was talk that Mark's father must be caught up with organized crime. So at 15 Mark started calling around until his mother made him stop.
马克的父亲是加利福尼亚州弗雷斯诺市一家酒吧的老板。两名男子进入酒吧，打了一场台球，点了两杯啤酒，然后进入后室将他枪杀。他们没有拿走任何钱。这是一场黑帮风格的暗杀。有传言说马克的父亲一定卷入了有组织犯罪。所以15岁那年，马克开始四处打听，直到他母亲让他停下来。
17 years later, he moved back to Fresno. By this time he was a reporter for the LA Times. And he wanted to write a book investigating his dad's murder. He was so skittish that he and his wife got their home under assumed names, did not tell people where they lived.
17年后，他搬回了弗雷斯诺。此时他已是《洛杉矶时报》的一名记者。他想写一本书调查他父亲的谋杀案。他当时非常警觉，他和妻子以化名租了房，不告诉别人他们住在哪。
It's hard to make sense of all that. But there was a great deal of paranoia. I didn't want family to really know what I was doing. And I thought that if there was some way to-- if someone got nervous about the questions I was asking, I wanted to make it difficult for them to try to find me. And I remember changing my sleep patterns, so that I was awake all through the night, and I was guarding the house. I had, actually, a gun that I had under the couch. I was sleeping on the couch.
很难理解这一切。但当时确实有强烈的妄想症。我不想让家人真正知道我在做什么。我心想，如果有什么办法——如果有人因为我问的问题而感到不安，我想让他们难以找到我。我记得我改变了作息，彻夜不眠，守着房子。我甚至在沙发底下藏了一把枪。我就睡在沙发上。
In a way, I became very childlike again. I really had to become a 15-year-old again in some ways to get at this thing.
在某种程度上，我又变得非常幼稚。为了弄清这件事，我在某些方面真的不得不再次变回15岁。
Like how do you mean?
比如你是怎么理解的？
Well, I think it wasn't terribly adult to try to think that you could come back to your hometown and try to hide your identity. I don't think that was really adult.
嗯，我想试图回到家乡并隐藏身份，这并不是特别成熟的想法。我不认为那真的很成熟。
When somebody close to us dies, part of us can remain suspended there at the moment it happened. And we stay there. Part of us stays there, turning the whole thing over and over in our heads. Mark spent three years talking to informants about his father's murder. He went through police files, analyzed phone records, and in the end found credible evidence that his father was murdered just as he was about to blow the whistle on a drug ring, one with local police on its side, Mark believes.
当亲近的人去世时，我们的一部分可能会停留在事情发生的那一刻。我们停滞在那里。我们的一部分留在了那里，在脑海中反复咀嚼整件事。马克花了三年时间与线人谈论他父亲的谋杀案。他查阅了警方档案，分析了电话记录，最终找到了可信的证据，证明他的父亲就是在准备举报一个贩毒集团时被谋杀的，而马克认为这个集团有当地警方撑腰。
He wrote his book about it. It's called In My Father's Name. And still that was not enough. He's still not at peace.
他写了关于此事的书，名为《以我父亲之名》。但即便如此还是不够。他依然无法获得平静。
And have I been liberated by some of those answers? I don't know if liberation's the right word.
那么我得到一些答案后解脱了吗？我不知道“解脱”这个词是否合适。
But why? What would it take?
但为什么呢？怎样才能做到？
I think there is a part of me that wants to sit across from the men who set this whole thing up and talk to them about it.
我想我内心的一部分人，想要坐在那些策划这一切的人对面，和他们谈谈。
You want them to admit it to your face.
你想让他们当面承认。
Yeah, that's right. That's what I want them to do. I have played over that encounter with the killers so many times. And one of the things that I would tell them going in is it goes no further than you and me. This is it. I just want to ask you one question. Were you responsible for the murder of my father?
是的，没错。这就是我希望他们做的。我已经在脑海中反复演练过与凶手的相遇。其中我会对他们说的一件事是，这件事到你我为止。就是这样。我只想问你一个问题。你是否对我父亲的谋杀负责？
And so, actually, you've actually imagined this over and over to yourself?
所以，实际上，你已经在心里反复想象过这个场景了？
Oh, I imagine it all the time.
哦，我一直都在想象。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, people trying to make sense out of things for which they'll never get answers or real peace. All three stories on our program today are about people facing the idea of death, and telling themselves one thing about it or another. And is there anything that can be said? Is there anything that can comfort us in that situation?
好了，来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：人们试图去理解那些永远无法获得答案或真正平静的事情。今天节目中的三个故事都是关于人们面对死亡的概念，并对自己讲述着这样或那样的道理。有什么话是可以说的吗？在那种情况下，有什么能安慰我们吗？
Act One of our program, The Disappearance, trying to comprehend what it means when people are there, alive in your life one day, and the next gone. Act Two, Look for the Union Label. A father and daughter sit down together for no real reason, just a whim really, to write his obituary, not really thinking about what it means. And then at some point someone starts to think about what it means. Act Three, Ashes. David Sedaris talks about the death of his mother. Stay with us.
节目第一幕，《失踪》，试图去理解当一个人昨天还在你的生活中鲜活地存在，而第二天却消失了，这意味着什么。第二幕，《寻找工会标签》。一对父女没有任何特别的理由，仅仅是一时兴起，坐下来写他的讣告，并没有真正去想这意味着什么。然后到了某个时刻，有人开始思考这意味着什么。第三幕，《灰烬》。大卫·塞达里斯讲述他母亲的去世。请继续收听。
Act One, The Disappearance. One of the most remarkable books that I've read in a while is by a woman named Genevieve Jurgensen, about her husband Laurent and she lost their two daughters, Elise and Mathilde, at the ages of four and seven. The book is a series of letters that she wrote to her friend 12 years after their deaths.
第一幕，《失踪》。我最近读到过一本非常出色的书，作者是一位名叫吉纳维芙·尤尔根森的女性。她和丈夫洛朗失去了两个女儿，埃莉斯和马蒂尔德，她们去世时分别只有四岁和七岁。这本书是她在女儿们去世12年后写给朋友的一系列信件。
And one of the things that's so remarkable about it is how she still struggles. She doesn't want to keep suffering over their deaths. But suffering over them is the last way that she has to love them. She's also keenly aware that she wants them to seem, in these letters, to be more than just names. You know, when you tell a story about somebody, it's sometimes hard for them to seem more like just a character in a story. And she keeps trying over and over to find ways to make it real, that in fact they were alive. They are more than can be expressed on the page.
这本书最引人注目的地方之一，是她依然在痛苦中挣扎。她不想继续为女儿们的去世而受苦。但为她们受苦是她爱她们的最后方式。她也敏锐地意识到，她希望在这些信中，女儿们不仅仅是名字。你知道，当你讲述一个人的故事时，有时很难让他们看起来不仅仅是故事里的一个角色。她不断地尝试寻找各种方法让这一切变得真实，事实是她们曾经活过。她们远不止能在纸面上表达的那样。
You never knew our daughters. Neither did you know me as I was when they were alive. I will have to tell you everything. Can one really tell someone about very young children? I will not even show you photographs of them. All they show are two little girls barely distinguishable from each other, just like all the little blond children which people primary school classes and the beaches along the Atlantic coast in the summer.
你从未见过我的女儿们。你也不了解她们还活着时我的样子。我必须告诉你一切。真的能向某人讲述年幼的孩子吗？我甚至不会给你看她们的照片。照片里不过是两个难以分辨的小女孩，就像大西洋沿岸夏天里随处可见的小学班级和海滩上的那些金发孩子。
On the 29th of April, 1980, the official photographer for the school which my daughters attended came to take some class photographs. They were both dead the next day. Indeed, we did not receive these photographs until several weeks after the news of our solitude. Mathilde's class is in uniform. So it is a picture of a little girl in navy blue in a row, stifling her giggles in between her best friends. Elise, who was still in the nursery class, is wearing the dress with the sailor collar that my mother gave her. She's sitting in the first row, looking solemnly at the lens. I think that in this picture she's really very like me.
1980年4月29日，我女儿所在学校的官方摄影师来拍摄班级照。第二天她们就都去世了。事实上，直到我们得知孤独的消息几周后，我们才收到这些照片。马蒂尔德的班级穿着制服。所以那是一张一个小女孩穿着海军蓝制服，在一排人中强忍着笑声，夹在好朋友中间的照片。当时还在幼儿园的埃莉斯，穿着我母亲送给她的水手领连衣裙。她坐在第一排，严肃地看着镜头。我觉得在这张照片里，她真的很像我。
In Mathilde's satchel I still have her school overall with her name embroidered on it, with its ink stains and biscuit crumbs in the pockets. In her exercise book, in her childish but careful handwriting, she has written the date which will be the date of her death and the death of her little sister, Wednesday, the 30th of April, 1980.
在马蒂尔德的书包里，我还留着绣着她名字的校服外套，口袋里还有墨水渍和饼干屑。在她的练习本上，用她那稚嫩但认真的笔迹，写着那天期，那将是她和她小妹妹去世的日子——1980年4月30日，星期三。
What else can I tell you? I would like you to have heard me talking to them just once, even if only on the telephone. I feel powerless in trying to make you accept this evidence they were here, I was their mother.
我还能告诉你什么呢？我真希望你哪怕只听过一次我跟她们说话，哪怕只是通过电话。在试图让你接受这些证据——她们曾经在这里，我是她们的母亲——这一点上，我感到无能为力。
I went to pick them up at school. We stopped at the supermarket to buy two cheap waxed coats, one in red, one in blue. And I dropped them off with my mother, not before playing a practical joke on her on the landing. I bundled my daughters up in the coats with the hoods up, pulled tightly over their noses and tied under their chins. They rang the bell and I hid. And my mother pretended not to recognize them.
我去学校接她们。我们在超市停下，买了件两件便宜的蜡布外套，一件红的，一件蓝的。我把她们送到我母亲那，在那之前，我在楼梯口跟她开了一个玩笑。我把女儿们裹在外套里，兜帽拉起，紧紧地盖住鼻子，在下巴下系好。她们按响了门铃，我躲了起来。我母亲假装没认出她们。
Then I went home, because I was a speech therapist at the time, and I had patients waiting. My sister-in-law came, as intended, to pick Mathilde and Elise up to take them to their other grandmother. But they never arrived, because they died toward the end of the afternoon about 10 meters from each other on the side of the Northern Highway.
然后我回家了，因为当时我是言语治疗师，还有病人在等我。我的嫂子按计划来接马蒂尔德和埃莉斯，带她们去见她们的另一个祖母。但她们从未到达，因为她们在下午快结束时，在北方高速公路的路边，相距约10米的地方去世了。
I'm hesitating about what to write next. There is no common ground between before and after, or at least what they have in common strikes me as just as painful to excavate as the most deeply-buried relics of before. Yes, I'm hesitating. I'm afraid of failing. I'm afraid that you will believe more readily in their death than in their lives.
我正犹豫着接下来该写什么。在“之前”和“之后”之间没有共同点，或者说，它们共同拥有的东西，对我来说，挖掘起来和挖掘埋藏最深的“之前”的遗迹一样痛苦。是的，我犹豫了。我害怕失败。我害怕你会比相信她们的生命更容易相信她们的死亡。
A few years ago, I still used to drive out into the countryside and bellow at the top of my lungs, Mathilde. I was really calling her. Of course, she did not come. At least I had spoken her name once more. Sometimes I meet a little girl who has the same name as her, and I speak it. I say, hello, Mathilde, goodbye, Mathilde, with a smile. And I think, help.
几年前，我还会开车去乡下，扯着嗓子大喊：马蒂尔德！我是在真的呼唤她。当然，她没有来。至少我再次叫出了她的名字。有时我会遇到一个名字和她一样的小女孩，我会叫她。我会微笑着说，你好，马蒂尔德，再见，马蒂尔德。我想，救救我。
On the eve of that May Day holiday, we were not expecting anyone to call, and the ringing of the telephone awakened no feelings in us. We lifted the receiver without curiosity. A slight rustling on the line indicated that the call was being made from outside Paris. My sister? No, I knew she was on her way to Paris. An unfamiliar man's voice checked that we were indeed the people he was looking for. Then he told us to hold the line.
在五一劳动节假期的前夕，我们没指望有人会来电话，电话铃声也没有引起我们的任何感觉。我们毫无好奇心地接起了听筒。线路里轻微的沙沙声表明是从巴黎以外打来的。是我妹妹吗？不，我知道她在去巴黎的路上。一个陌生的男声确认了我们是否就是他在寻找的人。然后他让我们保持通话。
The next voice was that of our brother-in-law, Christian, who had left with his wife, their baby, and our two girls. We asked him how he was. He said that he was not good at all, that they had had a very serious car accident. We said, yes, and? He told us our two little girls were dead. We thought he was playing a joke on us, and then thought no one would play a joke in such poor taste. Laurent said, but Christian, it's not true. He fell to his knees, calling his children.
下一个声音是我妹夫克里斯蒂安的，他和他的妻子、婴儿以及我们的两个女儿一起离开了。我们问他怎么样。他说他一点都不好，他们发生了一场非常严重的车祸。我们说，是吗，然后呢？他告诉我们两个小女儿死了。我们以为他在跟我们开玩笑，随后想到没有人会开这种恶劣的玩笑。洛朗说，克里斯蒂安，这不是真的。他跪倒在地，呼唤着他的孩子们。
I asked for news of the others. Everyone was fine. Where did we have to go? To the hospital at Peronne. I did not know where it was. Christian give us a few directions. Laurent knew. We hung up.
我询问其他人的消息。大家都很好。我们要去哪里？去佩罗讷的医院。我不知道它在哪里。克里斯蒂安给了我们一些指引。洛朗知道。我们挂断了电话。
I immediately felt how impossible it was to raise myself to the scale of this event. The terror mounted in me out of all proportion to my own dimensions. I could not contain it all. I was still this little woman in her little apartment next to a little man in the same little apartment. The terror targeted us exclusively. We were its only prey, its only destination, the terminus. It was a giant, and we were dwarves.
我立刻感觉到，要让自己达到这一事件的规模是多么不可能。恐惧在我心中升腾，与我自身的大小完全不成比例。我无法容纳这一切。我依然是那个小公寓里的小女人，身边是同一个小公寓里的小男人。恐惧专门针对我们。我们是它唯一的猎物，唯一的目的地，终点站。它是巨人，我们是侏儒。
Laurent took me by the wrists and asked me not to scream. He said, to think we're going to have to get over this. A big part of us has stayed there forever. I will tell you what happened next, everything you want to know about what happened next. But at the moment I can not. Just as then, I am looking for the link between my daughters and that news.
洛朗抓住我的手腕，让我不要尖叫。他说，想想我们必须挺过去。我们的一部分永远留在了那里。我会告诉你接下来发生了什么，关于之后发生的一切你想知道的。但此刻，我不能。就像当时一样，我正在寻找我的女儿们与那个消息之间的联系。
We arrived at the door of the hospital. Jean-Bernard asked where we had to go. And the porter replied, in surgery. Then I thought that my daughters had been operated on before they died. And everything expanded into infinity again. Corridors. It was difficult to walk. My sister-in-law at the end of the corridor, arms circling around her, a room. My brother-in-law, my sister-in-law, a stranger.
我们到达了医院门口。让-贝尔纳问我们该去哪。门房回答，在手术室。然后我想，我的女儿们在去世前被动了手术。一切又膨胀到无穷大。走廊。走得很艰难。嫂子在走廊尽头，双臂环抱着自己，一个房间。我的妹夫，我的嫂子，一个陌生人。
They ask us if we would like to see them, if we wanted to see our daughters. You would have had to drag me there with a tractor. They ask us if we would like to ring anyone to let them know. I then understand that this horror does not stop at us, that we have to tell my mother. No, it's the evening. She is not expecting any news this evening. Let her sleep one more time.
他们问我们是否想见她们，是否想看看我们的女儿。你得用拖拉机才能把我拖过去。他们问我们是否想给谁打电话告知情况。我这时明白，这种恐惧并没有止于我们，我们还得告诉我的母亲。不，现在是晚上。她今晚不指望有任何消息。让她再睡最后一觉吧。
I was right. They need the family record book. When they ask for it, and I reply, yes, we've brought it with us, I feel proud for a moment. We are good parents. We thought of everything. Aline and Christian are going to spend the night in hospital near their baby, Aude. All three are kept under observation.
我是对的。他们需要家庭记录簿。当他们索要时，我回答，是的，我们带在身上，那一刻我感到自豪。我们是好父母。我们想到了一切。艾琳和克里斯蒂安要在医院陪伴他们的孩子奥德过夜。三人都在观察中。
We are taken back. In fact, we came for nothing. Right from the first instant, death is this nothing.
我们被带了回来。事实上，我们白跑了一趟。从最初的那一刻起，死亡就是这种虚无。
Mrs. L suggests that we stay the night at her house. I agree readily. She lost a son long ago. At the Ls' house, we eat what we are given, food and sleeping pills.
L夫人建议我们去她家过夜。我欣然同意。她很久以前失去了一个儿子。在L夫人家，我们吃着给我们的东西，食物和安眠药。
It is not so much in words that I'm lacking to tell you all this, but in courage. When I realize that I have forgotten something, and I have to retrace my steps, I say to myself, is it really worth it?
向你讲述这一切，我缺少的与其说是言语，不如说是勇气。当我意识到我遗漏了什么，并且不得不回头重来时，我对自己说，真的值得吗？
Before taking the sleeping pill, we thought that over at La Haye their grandparents were waiting for our daughters. Laurent's parents. Have I told you that they were attending the coronation of Queen Beatrix of Holland? Have I told you that on the 30th of April, 1980, this young woman was rising to the throne, and that ever since, this date has been celebrated there as a joyful anniversary of an event whose secondary effect was the death of the girls? That my father-in-law, the French ambassador, and my mother-in-law were attending the festivities? That all the embassy staff were busy, so we had found no one to go and fetch the girls at the airport? That resigned only at the very last minute, I had canceled the places reserved for them on the Air France flight?
在吃安眠药之前，我们想在拉艾的祖父母们正在等我们的女儿。洛朗的父母。我告诉过你他们正在参加荷兰贝娅特丽克丝女王的加冕典礼吗？我告诉过你1980年4月30日，这位年轻女性登上了王位，从那时起，这个日子在那里被庆祝为一个快乐的周年纪念，而其附带影响却是女孩们的死亡吗？我告诉过你我的岳父——法国大使，和我的岳母正在参加庆祝活动吗？所有的使馆工作人员都很忙，所以我们找不到人去机场接女孩们吗？只有在最后一分钟才放弃，我取消了预留给她们的法航机票吗？
Have I told you that at my mother's house, before they were picked up by their aunt, they had watched the coronation ceremony on television, as I had done out of the corner of my eye at home? Have I told you that, seeing my father-in-law's very characteristic form and gait, I telephoned my mother to ask whether everyone had spotted him? And I can still hear in the background Mathilde's voice full of disappointment, no, I didn't see him. The very, very last time. My mother told me that at the time Elise was turned away from the television, absorbed in her drawing, but that that had not stopped her from affirming energetically, but I did. I saw him.
我告诉过你，在我母亲家，在被姑妈接走之前，她们在电视上看了加冕仪式，就像我当时在家心不在焉看的那样吗？我告诉过你，看到我岳父非常鲜明的身形和步伐，我打电话给母亲问大家有没有发现他吗？我依然能听到背景里马蒂尔德失望的声音：不，我没看到他。那是最后、最后一次。我母亲告诉我，当时埃莉斯背对着电视，沉浸在画画中，但这并没有阻止她有力地肯定：但我看到了。我看到他了。
Since then, I have not called Mathilde nor Elise. Or if I have called my eldest daughter, it was without the hope that she would reply. It was to feel the vibration in my larynx of those syllables chosen when I was 25 years old. The arrangement of clear vowels and aquatic consonants which were to name the first of my children, to accompany her all her life, to act as her passport, announce her arrival, to be said with only a hint of shyness, and finally in the mouth of the one who would love her, to betray all the emotions that this girl would one day elicit, that she alone would arouse in one young man, a young man who will never know her, who lives and who does not live to love her.
从那以后，我没有再叫过马蒂尔德，也没有叫过埃莉斯。或者如果我叫了我大女儿的名字，那也是不抱任何她会回应的希望。那是为了感受喉咙里那些在我25岁时选择的音节的震动。那些清澈的元音和灵动辅音的排列，原本是为了命名我的第一个孩子，伴随她一生，作为她的护照，宣布她的到来，带着一丝羞怯说出口，并最终在爱她的人口中，流露出这个女孩有一天会引发的所有情感，那是她独自在一个年轻男人心中唤起的，一个永远不会认识她、活着却从未为了爱她而活的年轻男人。
After the funeral, I went over to my mother to see my aunt and uncle, who would soon be returning to Haute-Savoie. The concierge came out of her lodge to see me as I went into the building. Mathilde often used to go over to play with her daughter. She said, you will see. You can get used to anything. It is certainly the most simple, true, brutal, and perceptive thing that anyone said to me at the time. You could interpret it either as a message of hope or of crushing contempt for human nature.
葬礼后，我去看望我母亲，见到了即将返回上萨瓦省的叔叔阿姨。当我走进大楼时，礼宾员从门房出来看我。马蒂尔德过去常去她家和她的女儿玩。她说，你会看到的。你可以习惯任何事情。这无疑是当时别人对我说的最简单、真实、残酷且富有洞察力的话。你可以将其理解为希望的信息，或者对人性的巨大蔑视。
It is very strange, this double rhythm that I have with you. I write to you, forcing myself to clarify a period of my life that I've done everything I can to understand, but which has always been out of my grasp. It is said that reality outstrips fiction, but this is something else. The reality remains inaccessible. Since the death of the girls-- 12 years in 16 days' time-- I have honestly and constantly tried to unveil this reality without success.
和你在一起，这种双重节奏非常奇怪。我写信给你，强迫自己澄清我生活中一段我竭尽全力去理解，却总是无法触及的时期。俗话说现实超越虚构，但这又是另一回事。现实仍然无法触及。自女孩们去世——16天后就满12年了——我诚实且持续地试图揭开这个现实，却未果。
Perhaps I've already told you, sometimes I believe in them alive, my darling children, my darling little girls. These words which are so light and yet so burdensome cut through me then. And sometimes I believe in their death on the edge of the motorway, 10 or so meters from each other, their legs in dungarees, their arms and heads on the side of the motorway. There is never a link between the two.
也许我已经告诉过你，有时我相信她们还活着，我亲爱的孩子们，我亲爱的小女儿们。这些如此轻盈却又如此沉重的话语在那时刺痛了我。有时我又相信她们死在高速公路边，相距10米左右，她们穿着牛仔裤的腿，她们的手臂和头躺在高速公路边。这两者之间从来没有联系。
The other rhythm constitutes things I do in my current life, as if nothing had happened. Conversations, laughter, mutual friends, a double rhythm like a double life. You do not know whether they struggle against each other or enrich each other.
另一种节奏构成了我在当前生活中所做的事情，仿佛什么都没发生过。谈话、笑声、共同的朋友，一种双重节奏就像一种双重生活。你不知道它们是在相互斗争还是相互丰富。
Have I already mentioned Yasser Arafat to you? This is what made me think of him. When Elise was born, I found myself battling with a huge, hungry baby. The few odd ounces of milk that I was able to supply in the first 24 hours of her life in hospital were definitely not enough for her, and she screamed constantly. With Mathilde crying down the telephone because she felt lost without me, I quickly lost my patience. I found myself brutally grasping Elise's cradle, which was on casters, and furiously pushing it away from my bed, so that it was in danger of banging into the far wall. A second of silence, and then the crying started up again.
我跟你提过亚西尔·阿拉法特吗？这就是让我想起他的原因。埃莉斯出生时，我发现自己正在和一个巨大的、饥饿的婴儿作斗争。我最初24小时能供给的少量母乳对她来说显然不够，她一直在尖叫。随着马蒂尔德因为没有我在身边而感到失落，在电话那头哭泣，我很快失去了耐心。我粗暴地抓住埃莉斯的摇篮，它是带脚轮的，狂怒地把它从床边推开，以至于它差点撞到远处的墙上。一秒钟的沉默，然后哭声再次响起。
On the third day, my mother came to see me. She sat at the end of the bed and chatted. We were cheerful. We, the adults, were talking to each other, but I was looking at my daughter, who was looking back at me. Drawn by her gaze, I leaned over her and rubbed my nose on hers. She said, huh, huh. I stared at my mother to reassure myself that I had not dreamed it. It had quite knocked the breath out of her. I did the same thing again, and Elise replied again. Third attempt, third exchange. And that was it, she was my child, my treasure, my stupefaction.
第三天，我母亲来看我。她坐在床脚聊天。我们很愉快。我们这些成年人在交谈，但我看着我的女儿，她也在看着我。被她的目光吸引，我凑过去，用我的鼻子蹭她的鼻子。她说，嗯，嗯。我盯着我母亲，以确认我不是在做梦。这让她惊得说不出话来。我又做了一次，埃莉斯再次回应。第三次尝试，第三次交流。就是这样，她是我的孩子，我的宝贝，我的震惊。
For logistical reasons, it was my mother who came with Mathilde to pick me up from the hospital. I went down one of the big staircases. At the end of one of the ground-floor corridors, I saw Mathilde in her little green loden coat. She was watching silently, motionless, her nose pointing up another staircase. My mother pointed me out to her, and Mathilde started to walk towards me slowly. I handed Elise to my mother so that I could lift Mathilde into her rightful place in my arms. I can still feel to the nearest ounce the pressure of her legs around my waist. She did not say anything, but she slowly and silently felt my face with her hands like a blind girl.
出于后勤原因，是我母亲带着马蒂尔德来医院接我。我走下一条大楼梯。在底层走廊的一端，我看到了穿着绿色毛呢小外套的马蒂尔德。她静静地看着，一动不动，鼻子指向另一条楼梯。我母亲指点她看我，马蒂尔德开始缓慢地走向我。我把埃莉斯交给母亲，以便能把马蒂尔德抱进她在我怀里应有的位置。我依然能精准地感受到她双腿环绕我腰部的压力。她什么也没说，只是像个盲女一样，缓慢而沉默地用双手摸索我的脸。
During this rediscovery, this tender and cautious reunion, my mother was smiling and whispering sweet nothings to Elise. She had brown hair, olive skin, and huge eyes ringed with black kohl. And to confront the October weather, she was wearing a woolen hat which was a bit too big for her, which skewed sideways over her ear. She could be Yasser Arafat's daughter, my mother laughed.
在这种重新发现、这种温柔而谨慎的重逢中，我母亲微笑着，对埃莉斯呢喃着甜言蜜语。她留着棕色头发，橄榄色皮肤，大大的眼睛上围着黑色的眼影。为了对抗十月的天气，她戴着一顶对她来说有点太大的羊毛帽，帽檐歪向耳边。她可以是亚西尔·阿拉法特的女儿，我母亲笑着说。
The other day, the radio announced that Yasser Arafat's plane had disappeared in a sandstorm in the Libyan desert. A few hours later, although the members of his entourage were killed or injured, he himself was found alive and grinning. Every time that a tragic event affects him but spares him-- the murder of an adviser, all sorts of attempts on his life, or an airplane crash-- I feel that hug again. When I think of the life he leads and the life that Elise led, when I think of the life expectancy they each had on that October day when my mother teased me about my daughter, to think that she is dead, and he is here.
前几天，收音机宣布亚西尔·阿拉法特的飞机在利比亚沙漠的沙尘暴中失踪了。几个小时后，尽管随行人员有的死亡有的受伤，他本人却被发现活着，脸上还带着笑。每次发生影响他却又让他幸免于难的悲剧事件——顾问的谋杀、各种暗杀企图，或者飞机失事——我都会再次感受到那个拥抱。当我想起他过的生活和埃莉斯过的生活，当我想起我母亲拿我女儿开玩笑的那天十月份，她们每人本该拥有的预期寿命，想到她已经死了，而他却在这里。
I've been careful. I've never watched the home movies in which my two daughters appear, nor have I listened to their voices on the answering machine tapes that my mother kept. The messages to Granny are at her house, accessible, but I do nothing about it.
我一直很小心。我从来没有看过我两个女儿出现的家庭录像，也没有听过我母亲保留的电话答录机里的声音。给外婆的消息在她们家里，可以听到，但我什么也没做。
How many catastrophes have there been since I began this correspondence with you? Football stadiums collapse, young motorbikers kill each other at the 24-hour race in Le Mans, and here I am with the children and you. And I tug at my net, which has plunged so deep in the water.
自从我开始和你通信以来，发生了多少灾难？足球场坍塌，年轻的摩托车手在勒芒24小时耐力赛中自杀，而我和孩子们还有你在这里。我扯着我那深深沉入水中的网。
Last week, I spent a long time looking at a car exactly like the one in which my daughters fell asleep, from which they were thrown, in which, leaving their parents to go to their grandparents, they left Paris never to return. I was there looking at the back seat, the seat belts that we had not done up, the right-hand window out of which they would have both been thrown. The letters on the number plate confirmed that this Renault 5 was from the same year as my sister-in-law's. They're still on the road, those cars. When there are none left, I will no longer be able to ask questions of them. Someone will have to keep one somewhere for me.
上周，我看了很久一辆车，和我的女儿们睡着时乘坐的那辆一模一样，她们就是从那辆车里被甩出来的，在那辆车里，她们离开父母去祖父母家，离开了巴黎，却再也没有回来。我就在那看着后座，那些我们没扣上的安全带，她们两人就是从右侧车窗被甩出去的。车牌上的字母证实，这辆雷诺5和嫂子的是同一年份的。那些车还在路上跑着。等一辆都不剩了，我就无法再向它们询问什么了。有人得为我保留一辆放在某处。
After the impact, when my sister-in-law managed to bring her car to a halt, she and her husband turned with relief to smile at the children, but only their baby was there, sitting in her little seat, stupefied with some fragments of glass spread over her. Have I already told you that? I tell it to myself so many times. When I was near that Renault 5 the other day, I wanted to lie down on the rear seat and wait for the end of time. In short, back to square one.
撞击发生后，当嫂子设法把车停下来时，她和丈夫如释重负地转过身对着孩子们微笑，但只有她们的婴儿在，坐在她的小座椅上，因为身上溅满了玻璃碎片而惊呆了。我跟你说过吗？我对自己说了这么多次。前几天当我在那辆雷诺5附近时，我想躺在后座上，等待时间的尽头。简而言之，回到原点。
I have some work to hand in, a lot, but nothing will get done until I've written to you. At first it was the other way around. Everything came before writing these letters. I used to tell myself, why suffer? What's the point of this artificial rendezvous with these long-lost children? I always had something happier to do. Now, even as I get up, I am carried by the things I want to write to you.
我有工作要交，很多，但在写信给你之前，什么也做不成。起初情况恰恰相反。一切都排在写这些信之前。我曾经对自己说，为什么要受苦？与这些失踪已久的孩子们进行这种人工约会有什么意义？我总有更快乐的事情要做。现在，即使我起床，也被我想写给你的事情所带动。
I should have gone to see in that room in the hospital where they put my daughters. I knew as soon as they suggested it to me. I knew that by refusing I was setting a precedent for a future of weakness because I was not worthy of-- I do not know what, just not worthy. So I did not go to see them dead. They were there, and Mummy did not come. They were only one or two rooms away. They remained alone. Mummy did not cross the doorway.
我本应该去医院那个房间看看，他们把我女儿放进去的地方。他们向我建议时我就知道了。我知道，拒绝就意味着为未来的软弱开创了先例，因为我不配——我不知道什么，只是不配。所以我没有去看她们的遗体。她们就在那里，而妈妈没有来。她们只隔了一两间房。她们依然孤独。妈妈没有跨过那道门槛。
I know nothing of their faces as they were at the end. They had the strength to die, and I could not match their strength. I know nothing of their last great achievement. Wherever they went, they went alone, together or apart. And I'm inclined to believe it was apart. Ignorant of their own heroism, they went to the places dictated by their violent trajectory at more than 100 kilometers per hour over the safety barrier.
我对她们最后的样子一无所知。她们有勇气去死，而我却无法匹配她们的勇气。我对她们最后伟大的壮举一无所知。无论她们去了哪里，她们都是独自前往，要么在一起，要么分开。我倾向于相信是分开的。在对自己的英勇一无所知的情况下，她们以每小时100多公里的速度越过安全护栏，前往那暴力轨迹所决定的地方。
I stayed on my chair like a lump. And since then, people have not stopped congratulating me for my courage as a mother, to such an extent that many friends, including you, hesitated before talking to us about the difficulties and hardships they were facing. They did not seem worthy in comparison. Laurent and I sat enthroned on a pedestal, hoisted there by the annihilation of our two little girls. But we still knew what real life was, like a weather map of constantly changing skies, and we needed people to tell us about it, because the air was thin for our two statues.
我像个木头人一样坐在椅子上。从那以后，人们就没停止过称赞我作为母亲的勇气，以至于许多朋友，包括你在内，在和我们谈论他们面临的困难和苦难之前都犹豫不决。相比之下，他们似乎不那么重要。洛朗和我坐在基座上，被我们两个小女孩的毁灭抬到了那里。但我们仍然知道什么是真实的生活，就像天气地图上不断变化的天空，我们需要人们告诉我们，因为对我们这两座雕像来说，空气太稀薄了。
The only stance that I battle against is to threaten suicide, to keep those around you on tenterhooks because you claim you're going to die. Watch out, I'm going to kill myself. My goodness, the living can make a fuss with their moods, and their other half running all over the place trying to stop them. I'm going to kill myself, watch out, watch out. Oh no, that is not how you do it.
我反对的唯一姿态是以自杀相威胁，让周围的人一直处于紧张状态，因为你声称你要死了。小心，我要自杀。天哪，活着的人可以因为情绪发脾气，另一半跑来跑去试图阻止他们。我要自杀，小心，小心。噢不，那不是你应该做的方式。
I will explain to these maniacs how Mathilde and Elise managed to die. If I can, that is, because they did the whole thing by themselves. And when the adults came to their senses and began to realize that they were no longer in the car, not even under the front seats, where they looked once they realized the rear seat was empty, when they had to resign themselves to getting out of the car to look for them-- they had to be found wherever they might be. When it was done, and they had been found dozens of meters from the car and dozens of meters apart, they had actually already gone without a word to a place that no man can see.
我会向这些狂人解释马蒂尔德和埃莉斯是怎么设法死去的。如果我能的话，因为她们是独自完成这一切的。当大人们恢复理智，开始意识到她们不在车里，甚至不在前座下面——他们在意识到后座是空的时曾找过——当他们不得不忍受下车去寻找她们——她们必须在她们可能在的任何地方被找到。当一切完成，她们在距离车子几十米远、相距几十米的地方被发现时，她们其实已经没说一句话就去了任何人都看不见的地方。
All of this brings me back to that moment of weakness on my chair when-- even though two children, my two children, two very young children, had known how to die and were waiting to be presented to me one last time in their truthfulness-- I had not even gone those few meters along the corridor that separated them from me. They had known how to die. I no longer knew how to walk.
这一切把我带回了我在椅子上软弱的那一刻——尽管两个孩子，我的两个孩子，两个非常年幼的孩子，已经知道如何去死，并等待着在最后一次真实中呈现在我面前——我甚至没有走过那条把她们与我隔开的几米走廊。她们知道如何去死。我却不再知道如何行走。
There has been nothing glorious about the way I live my life. I love the living in all their miasma. I love the dead for their temerity. There is nothing in between.
我过生活的方式没有任何光荣之处。我爱所有沉浸在污浊中的生者。我爱死者的无畏。中间什么都没有。
Our children now, Elvire and Gauthier, have asked us 100 times whether they would have been born if their sisters had not died. I really hope so, but I just can not say. The girls' death allowed me to be pregnant again, which I wanted anyway, to have other children, which I wanted anyway.
我们的孩子们，埃尔维尔和高蒂尔，已经问过我们100次，如果她们的姐姐们没死，他们还会出生吗？我真的很希望如此，但我无法肯定。女孩们的死亡让我能够再次怀孕，这是我无论如何都想要的，拥有其他的孩子，也是我无论如何都想要的。
Even so, at the square with the children, I was not like other mothers, sitting on the bench or on the side of the sand pit. I would watch my Elvire making mud pies, and I would let Gauthier suck on his biscuit. If another woman wanted to talk to me, I had only two options: a bright facade, which devastated me. "Yes, mine's already three and 1/2, but she's still frightened of the slide. I can't believe your little scrap. He's so brave up at the top of the ladder." Or a truth that was socially unacceptable. "These are my younger two children. The elder ones died four years ago."
即便如此，在广场和孩子们在一起时，我也不像其他母亲，坐在长椅上或沙坑边。我会看着我的埃尔维尔做泥饼，我会让高蒂尔吸吮饼干。如果另一个女人想和我说话，我只有两个选择：一张让我痛苦的明亮面具。“是的，我的已经三岁半了，但她还是怕滑梯。我不敢相信你这个小家伙，他在梯子顶上多勇敢。”或者一个在社会上无法接受的真相。“这是我较小的两个孩子。大的四个年前去世了。”
I would always be out of place. The working class, immigrants, the self-taught cranks, the handicapped, the unemployed, and grieving parents are more alike than people think. They have at least one thing in common. They have to make herculean efforts to hold a normal, banal, bouncy conversation. They can think of only one thing, the moment when they might introduce a sentence about their misfortune. 13 years have passed, and I still cannot last half a day without evoking my daughters.
我总是显得格格不入。工人阶级、移民、自学成才的怪人、残疾人、失业者和悲伤的父母比人们想象的更相似。他们至少有一个共同点。他们必须付出巨大的努力才能进行一场正常的、平庸的、活泼的对话。他们只能想一件事，那个可能会引出关于他们不幸的一句话的时刻。13年过去了，我依然无法撑过半天而不提起我的女儿们。
Elvire has received a postcard from a friend announcing the death of a classmate. I was having a siesta. In my drowsy state I could hear the voice of my 12-year-old daughter talking to her father, respecting her mother's sleep. I'm going to have to tell Gauthier, aren't I? He was playing with his cousin. Gauthier does not want to hear about anything to do with death. So when Elvire told him, he hid his feelings and hardly broke off from his game. And Elvire was left alone with this news, which she had just learned from one of those holiday cards that should never give you that sort of news.
埃尔维尔收到了一张来自朋友的明信片，宣布了一位同学的死讯。我当时在午睡。在昏昏欲睡的状态下，我能听到我12岁女儿的声音在和她父亲交谈，顾及母亲的睡眠。我得告诉高蒂尔，不是吗？他当时在和表弟玩。高蒂尔不想听到任何关于死亡的事情。所以当埃尔维尔告诉他时，他隐藏了自己的感受，几乎没有中断游戏。埃尔维尔独自面对这个消息，这是她从那些本不该带给你那种消息的度假贺卡中得知的。
What's going on, I asked, pretending to have heard nothing and feeling sure that Elvire would want to tell me everything herself. She joined me on the bed, buried herself against me, sighed, and then cried. She had been telling me about this friend's illness since the beginning of the school year. I knew that Lauren came to school sporadically, that she had changed physically, that her mother, who was always cheerful, came to pick her up from school with her two younger children, asking her whether she had forgotten anything in her locker as you would to a child who still has 10 or 15 years of school ahead of them. Then that was it. Lauren sank into a coma.
怎么了，我问，假装什么也没听到，并确信埃尔维尔会想自己告诉我一切。她来到床上，埋在我身边，叹了口气，然后哭了。自从开学以来，她一直告诉我这个朋友的病情。我知道劳伦断断续续地来学校，她的外貌发生了变化，她那总是开朗的母亲带着两个更小的孩子来学校接她，问她是否在储物柜里忘了什么，就像对一个还有15年学业要走的孩子那样。然后就是那样了。劳伦陷入了昏迷。
Elvire had told me about that too. But now, as she cried, she realized she had never imagined that Lauren would actually die. And this death, this end to everything, this earthly truth which meant that the child who had been told not to forget anything in her locker would not begin the next academic year in three weeks time, this was so harsh and so invincible that Elvire had only her tears to link the two realities, that of a life, yesterday, which was complete even in a state of coma and death, which was eternal right from the first moment.
埃尔维尔也告诉过我这件事。但现在，当她哭泣时，她意识到自己从未想象过劳伦真的会死。这种死亡，这种一切的终结，这种大地上的真理，意味着那个被告知不要在储物柜里忘记任何东西的孩子，不会在三周后的新学年开始时出现，这是如此残酷和不可战胜，以至于埃尔维尔只能用眼泪来连接这两种现实：昨天的生命，即使在昏迷状态下也是完整的；以及死亡，从第一刻起就是永恒的。
Now, even as she struggled with the sharp pain, she already knew that soon, very soon, this pain would soften. And despite her sobs, her shuddering little frame, her puffy red face, she was already missing the purity of this revolt before it had even begun to fade. And she refused to accept that this sorrow would become integrated into her life. When I tell my children about this one day, they won't understand how horrible it was, she told me. And then, maybe even tomorrow there will already be moments when I don't think about it.
现在，即使她在剧痛中挣扎，她也已经知道，很快，很快，这种痛苦就会减轻。尽管她啜泣、颤抖的小身躯、红肿的脸，她已经开始怀念这种反抗的纯洁，尽管它还没有开始消退。她拒绝接受这种悲伤会融入她的生活。有朝一日我把这件事告诉我的孩子们，他们不会明白那是多么可怕，她告诉我。然后，可能明天就会有我不去想它的时刻。
This idea redoubled her anger. Far from hoping to suffer less, she never wanted the freshness of the pain to deaden. This was the only acceptable response to a disappearance that every part of her refused to accept. As I listened to her, I loved her for having already understood everything. And I thought of these letters, in which, so many years later, I try to discover exactly what has become of all those feelings.
这个想法加倍了她的愤怒。她不仅不希望少受一点苦，她也永远不希望痛苦的新鲜感消退。对于每一个部分都拒绝接受的消失，这是唯一可以接受的回应。当我听她诉说时，我爱她，因为她已经理解了一切。我想到了这些信，在多年后，我试图发掘所有那些感情到底变成了什么。
Genevieve Jurgensen's book is called The Disappearance. It's published by Norton. Excerpts were read by actress Felicity Jones.
吉纳维芙·尤尔根森的书名为《失踪》。由诺顿出版社出版。摘录由女演员菲丽希缇·琼斯朗读。
Coming up, more people trying to make sense of the senseless, including a story by David Sedaris. In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，更多试图理解那些无法理解之事的尝试，包括大卫·塞达里斯的故事。稍后，来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Look for the Union Label. In this act, two people, father and daughter-- we'll hear from them both-- start to compose a story about death before anybody has died.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《寻找工会标签》。在这一幕中，两个人，父女——我们都将听到他们的讲述——在任何人去世之前就开始创作一个关于死亡的故事。
Well, it simply began by sitting in the kitchen of my home, reading the Boston Globe. And I looked out on a beautiful fall day, looking out at a maple tree in front of my yard, and suddenly it occurred to me that I should write my obituary, or begin working on it. No special reason.
嗯，这很简单，只是坐在自己家的厨房里读《波士顿环球报》。那是一个美丽的秋日，我看着院子前面的枫树，突然想到我应该写我的讣告，或者开始着手准备。没有特别的理由。
It must have been probably over the Christmas holidays, probably last year.
那可能是在圣诞假期前后，大概是去年。
And you were visiting your parents' house?
你当时在拜访父母家？
My parents. Around that time. And I was on the telephone. And I was just looking for a pad of paper to write something down. And I just noticed on a yellow legal pad that my father had started writing his obituary.
我父母家。大概在那段时间。我在打电话。我只是想找个笔记本写点东西。我刚好注意到我父亲在一个黄色法律便签本上开始写他的讣告。
But it wasn't labeled obituary at the time?
但当时并没有写上“讣告”的标签？
No. No. It just said born in 1917 to Albany. And it just was incredibly straightforward and standard.
没有。没有。只是写了“1917年出生于奥尔巴尼”。非常直接和标准。
And I just couldn't believe it. I didn't actually have an emotional response to the obituary part at all. I was just sort of-- I guess I was amused in a way, because he is such an interesting person. And the writing was just sort of the most basic details about his family. And it didn't really say anything about him.
我简直不敢相信。我当时对讣告部分根本没有情感反应。我只是——我想我被逗乐了，因为他是一个如此有趣的人。而那些文字只是关于他家庭的最基本细节。根本没说出他这个人。
In other words, he's a more interesting person than the writing, itself.
换句话说，他本人比那些文字更有趣。
Right. And I don't know. And I didn't really process the thought. I just went straight to him. And I said, Dad, my god, this is so boring. I said, you've lived a much more interesting life than this. And he said, well, then help me write it. You're a writer. Help me write it. And all he knew was what the headline should be. That was sort of the one very clear thing that he knew.
没错。我不知道。我没怎么处理这个想法。我直接走向他，我说，爸，天哪，这太无聊了。我说，你活得比这有趣多了。他说，那帮我写吧。你是作家。帮我写。他唯一知道的就是标题应该是什么。那是他心里唯一非常清楚的事情。
And what should the headline be?
标题应该是什么？
The headline should be-- I'm named after him. And it should say Adrian LeBlanc, comma, Product of the Working Class. That was what he saw.
标题应该是——我以他的名字命名。它应该写“阿德里安·勒布朗，工人阶级的产物”。这就是他所想的。
Well, to me, that's very important, because when I say the working class, I'm talking about workers. Throughout my history, from the first factory job, first learning what a union was, and then being a committee man and president of local unions wherever I worked. And from there on, I gravitated toward becoming a full-time field representative. I tend to take positions, you know? I do this every day of my life. And I think that the obituary was like saying there are still union guys around. You follow?
嗯，对我来说，这非常重要，因为当我提到工人阶级，我指的是劳动者。纵观我的历史，从第一份工厂工作开始，第一次了解什么是工会，然后无论在哪里工作，都成为工会委员会成员和当地工会主席。从那以后，我倾向于成为一名全职的工会代表。我倾向于表明立场，你懂吗？我每天的生活都这样。我想讣告就像是在说：工会的人还在。你明白吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I don't know if that's clear. But that was pretty much it, just like saying, look, 82 years later, from 16 to 82, there are still guys who are making a pitch.
我不知道那是否清晰。但大致就是这样，就像是说：看，82年后，从16岁到82岁，还有人在努力发声。
And so we sit down. I'm pretty sure that first day we sat down. I opened my portable computer, and I said OK. And he said, so how do we do this? What do we do? And I said, well, I just need you to tell me about your life.
于是我们坐下来。我非常确定那天我们坐下来了。我打开便携式电脑，我说“好”。他说，“那我们要怎么做？我们做什么？”我说，“嗯，我只需要你告诉我你的生活。”
I've actually tried to do this with my dad before, not in the context of the obituary but in those moments where I felt, oh, I need to learn about my family history. But he was not very responsive. He would be very vague.
其实我以前就试过和爸爸这样做，不是在讣告的语境下，而是在我感觉到“噢，我需要了解我的家庭历史”的时候。但他不是很配合。他会非常含糊。
But for some reason, when he was thinking of his life in terms of an obituary, a lot of details came out that I don't feel I could've-- well, I wasn't able to get when I was trying to just have straight conversations with him about his biography, daughter to father.
但由于某种原因，当他从讣告的角度思考自己的一生时，出现了很多我感觉我无法——嗯，我以前以女儿对父亲的身份试图和他进行直接交谈时没能得到的细节。
I was wondering if it was an enjoyable process for you, talking to your daughter.
我很好奇这对他来说是否是一个愉快的过程，和你女儿交谈。
Yes. Yes. Yes. She's got a-- I find her to be a searcher and a prober with good instincts, and caring.
是的。是的。是的。她有一个——我发现她是一个有直觉且关怀他人的搜索者和探究者。
So I don't know. It was just interesting, and it came very easily. I learned so much about him.
所以我不知道。这只是很有趣，而且进行得非常顺利。我对他了解了很多。
Since it was an obituary you were writing, did the two of you talk about his death?
既然你们写的是讣告，你们俩谈论他的死亡了吗？
No. That's something that I think is-- I don't know. It's funny. In preparing for this, several of my friends were asking me about it. And it just sort of shocked me a little bit that they were thinking about it in that way. And then, of course, I realized it is an obituary.
没有。我想那是——我不知道。很有趣。在准备这期节目时，我的几个朋友问过我这个问题。他们那样想，确实让我有点震惊。当然，随后我意识到这确实是讣告。
I wonder if he understands it more the other way, that as far as he's concerned, it really is about his death.
我不知道他是否从另一个角度理解得更多，即就他而言，这确实是关于他的死亡。
I think he must. And I think over the years he's known how anxious my brother and I have been about him dying. So I think he often tries, in his way, to help us cope with it. He doesn't seem sort of nervous or frightened. So I don't know.
我想他一定理解。我想多年来他一直知道我和我弟弟对他会死亡感到多么焦虑。所以我认为他经常用自己的方式帮助我们应对。他看起来并不紧张或害怕。所以我不知道。
When I go to visit, I find leaving my parents sometimes quite difficult, because they are older. And I'm very busy. And I don't get back as often as I'd like to. And I think he knows how hard it is for me to say goodbye. And he'll say, I'm always with you. And I'll always be with you. That kind of thing.
当我回去探望时，我发现离开父母有时很困难，因为他们年纪大了。我很忙。我不能像我想的那样经常回去。我想他知道对我来说说再见有多难。他会说，“我永远和你在一起。我会永远和你在一起。”诸如此类的话。
I wonder if this whole process, you think you're doing it for him in a way, but maybe it's for you. He's doing this all for you.
我很好奇整个过程，你认为你在为他做这件事，但也许是为了你自己。他所做的一切都是为了你。
I believe that's very possible. I think that's very possible, which is probably why he was a good union organizer. Because I'm feeling like I'm helping him do something. He was good at what he did.
我相信这很有可能。我认为这很有可能，这大概就是为什么他是个好的工会组织者。因为我觉得我正在帮他完成某事。他在他做的事情上很出色。
Is one of the reasons that you've agreed to talk to your daughter about the obituary, and work with her on the obituary, is to help her prepare for the thought that you might die?
你同意和你女儿谈论讣告，并和她一起处理讣告的原因之一，是不是为了帮她准备好接受你可能会去世的想法？
It could be. I haven't stayed with that thought. But it could very well be, Ira. Maybe you're clueing in. I think that thought has crossed my mind, but I haven't stayed with it. I haven't stayed. But you could be partially right.
可能是。我没深究那个想法。但这很有可能，艾拉。也许你猜中了。我想那个想法在我脑海中闪过，但我没停留。我没停留。但你可能部分是对的。
Is there a way to ever-- I'm not sure I would want it to be easier. But I wonder if it's possible. Is it possible to even know what that could be like?
有没有办法可以——我不确定我希望它变得容易。但我怀疑这是否可能。甚至有可能知道那会是什么样子吗？
You're saying that no matter how we try to prepare for the death of somebody so close to us, there really is nothing we can do. We can think about it all we want.
你是说无论我们如何试图为亲近的人的死亡做准备，其实我们都无能为力。我们可以随心所欲地思考。
Yeah, I definitely feel that with it. I mean, because obviously I've been working on an obituary, not really thinking at all about my father dying, not thinking that it's about death, just thinking that it's about talking to my father, and that I have all the time to sort of figure this out. I don't know. It's part of my relationship with him will be what happens when it's over, when he's physically gone.
是的，我对此有确切的感觉。我的意思是，因为我显然一直在写一份讣告，根本没去想父亲会死，没想过这是关于死亡，只想到这是在和父亲交谈，而且我有所有的时间来弄清这一切。我不知道。这是我和他关系的一部分，也就是当一切结束时，当他在生理上消失后会发生什么。
I mean, my brother-in-law passed away. And he was quite sick before he died. And he was in a coma right up to the moment that he actually did die. And there was such a vast difference between him. Even though he wasn't available as the person we'd known, his physical life was so immense. And when it was gone, the loss of it was just huge. It was huge, and it happened in just a minute. And I just was so shocked by that, because I was so ready for him to die. We knew that he was going to die. He wasn't really with us anymore. And I was glad that I was able to at least understand how little I actually knew about it.
我的意思是，我的妹夫去世了。他在去世前病得很重。他直到实际去世的那一刻都处于昏迷状态。而他本人有着巨大的差异。尽管他作为我们所认识的那个人已经不在了，但他生理上的生命是如此巨大。当它消失时，失去它的代价是巨大的。它是巨大的，而且只在这一分钟内发生。我对此感到非常震惊，因为我当时对他的死亡做好了充分的准备。我们知道他会死。他不再真正和我们在一起了。我很高兴我至少能够理解我对这件事其实是多么无知。
So how far are the two of you on the obit? Have you finished it?
所以你们讣告写得怎么样了？完成了吗？
No. No, I haven't actually-- I can't figure out how to write it except in the past tense. And it just seems completely bizarre to speak of him in that way.
没有。没有，我其实还没法——除了用过去式，我想不出怎么写。以那种方式谈论他显得完全怪异。
So I understand she hasn't finished writing it.
所以我明白她还没写完。
No, we haven't completed it. No.
没有，我们还没完成。没有。
Do you feel like she's taking too long getting this done?
你觉得她完成得太慢了吗？
Do I think she's taking too long?
你觉得她太慢了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
No, I didn't feel there was any-- there's no great rush that I know of. Do you have a feeling there should be a timetable?
不，我不觉得有什么——据我所知没有很急。你觉得应该有个时间表吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不觉得。
Are you rushing the process, Ira? That's not very--
你在催促这个过程吗，艾拉？那不是很——
No. No, I have no intention to rush the process.
不。不，我没有催促过程的意图。
I'm not going anywhere. I'm still bowling on Fridays with the senior citizens.
我哪儿也不去。我依然在周五和老年公民们打保龄球。
Adrian LeBlanc and his daughter, also named Adrian LeBlanc.
阿德里安·勒布朗和他的女儿，也叫阿德里安·勒布朗。
[MUSIC - "THEY CAN'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM ME" BY BILLIE HOLLIDAY]
[音乐 - 比莉·荷莉黛演唱的《他们无法夺走这一切》]
When somebody dies we can be haunted by the thought of them. And we can also be haunted by the way that we acted ourselves toward them. This next story is a story of both kinds of haunting. Several years ago, three weeks before his sister Lisa's wedding, David Sedaris got a phone call from his mom, back home in Raleigh, North Carolina. She had lung cancer. She was a lifelong, unrepentant smoker.
当某人去世时，我们可能会被关于他们的想法所困扰。我们也可能被我们自己对待他们的方式所困扰。接下来的这个故事就是关于这两种纠缠。几年前，在姐姐丽莎婚礼前三周，大卫·塞达里斯接到了远在北卡罗来纳州罗利市的母亲打来的电话。她得了肺癌。她是一位终身、死不悔改的吸烟者。
My sister Amy was with me when my mother called. We passed the phone back and forth across my tiny New York kitchen, and then spent the rest of the evening lying in bed, trying to convince each other that our mother would get better, but never quite believing it.
母亲打电话时，姐姐艾米和我在一起。我们把电话在我纽约那小小的厨房里传来传去，然后那天剩下的时间都躺在床上，试图说服对方我们的母亲会好起来，但从未真正相信过。
I had heard of people who had survived cancer, but most of them claimed to get through it with the aid of whole grains and spiritual publications that encouraged them to sit quietly in a lotus position. They envisioned their tumors and tried to reason with them.
我听说过战胜癌症的人，但他们中的大多数声称通过全谷物和灵性出版物的帮助度过难关，这些出版物鼓励他们静静地盘腿坐着。他们想象着肿瘤并试图与它们理性沟通。
Our mother was not the type to greet the dawn or cook with oats and barley. She didn't reason, she threatened. And if that didn't work, she chose to ignore the problem. We couldn't picture her joining a support group or trotting through the mall in a warm-up suit.
我们的母亲不是那种会迎接黎明或用燕麦和大麦做饭的人。她不讲理，她威胁。如果那不起作用，她选择忽视问题。我们无法想象她会参加互助小组或穿着运动装在商场里走来走去。
62 years old, and none of us had ever seen her in a pair of slacks. I'm not certain why, but it seemed to me that a person needed a pair of pants in order to defeat cancer. Just as important, they needed a plan. They needed to accept the idea of a new and different future free of crowded ashtrays and five-gallon jugs of wine and Scotch. They needed to believe that such a life might be worth living. I didn't know that I'd be able to embrace such an unrewarding future, but I hoped that she could.
62岁了，我们谁也没见过她穿裤子。我不确定为什么，但我觉得一个人要想战胜癌症需要穿条裤子。同样重要的是，他们需要一个计划。他们需要接受一个远离满溢的烟灰缸、五加仑罐装葡萄酒和苏格兰威士忌的全新的不同未来的想法。他们需要相信这样的生活可能值得一过。我不知道我是否能够拥抱这样一个没有回报的未来，但我希望她能。
If she'd had it her way, we would have never known about the cancer. It was our father's idea to tell us, and she had fought it, agreeing only when he threatened to tell us himself. Our mother worried that once we found out, we would treat her differently, delicately. We might feel obliged to compliment her cooking and laugh at all of her jokes, thinking always of the tumor she was trying so hard to forget. And that is exactly what we did.
如果是她说了算，我们永远不会知道癌症的事。告诉我们那是父亲的主意，她曾抗争过，只有在他威胁要亲自告诉我们时才同意。母亲担心一旦我们发现，就会以不同的方式——小心翼翼地对待她。我们可能会感到有义务赞美她的厨艺，对她的笑话大笑，心里总是惦记着她竭力想忘记的肿瘤。而这正是我们所做的。
The knowledge of her illness forced everything into the spotlight and demanded that it be memorable. We were no longer calling our mother. Now we were picking up the telephone to call our mother with cancer. We realized that any conversation might be our last, and because of that, we wanted to say something important. But what could one say that hadn't already been printed on millions of greeting cards and helium balloons? I love you, I said at the end of one of our late night phone calls. I am going to pretend that I didn't hear that, she said. I heard a match strike in the background, the tinkling of ice cubes in a raised glass, and then she hung up.
她生病的消息把一切都推到了聚光灯下，要求一切变得值得纪念。我们不再是给母亲打电话。现在我们拿起电话，是给患癌的母亲打电话。我们意识到任何一次谈话都可能是最后一次，正因如此，我们想说些重要的话。但有什么话是没被印在数百万张贺卡和氦气球上过的呢？“我爱你”，我在一次深夜电话的末尾说。她说，“我会假装没听到那句话。”我听到背景里划火柴的声音，冰块在举起的酒杯里碰撞的清脆声，然后她挂断了电话。
I had never said such a thing to my mother. And if I had it to do over again, I would probably take it back. It was queer to say such a thing to someone unless you were trying to talk them out of money or into bed. Our mother had taught us this when we were no taller than pony kegs. I had known people who said such things to their parents. "I love you." But it always translated to mean, I'd love getting off the phone with you.
我从没对母亲说过这样的话。如果能重来一次，我可能会收回。除非你想找人借钱或骗上床，否则对某人说这种话是很怪的。母亲在我们还像小矮马那么高时就教过我们这一点。我认识有些人对父母说过这样的话。“我爱你”。但它总是被翻译为：我很乐意跟你挂断电话。
We gathered together for the wedding, which took place on a crisp, clear October afternoon. I took my mother's arm and led her to a bench beyond the range of the other guests. The thin mountain air made it difficult for her to breathe, and she moved slowly, pausing every few moments. The families had taken a walk to a nearby glen, and we sat in the shade, eating sausage biscuits and speaking to one another like well-mannered strangers.
我们为了婚礼聚在一起，那是在一个清爽、晴朗的十月午后。我挽着母亲的胳膊，把她带到客人范围外的一张长椅上。稀薄的山间空气让她呼吸困难，她移动缓慢，每隔一会儿就停下来。家人们去附近的山谷散步了，我们坐在阴影里，吃着香肠饼干，像彬彬有礼的陌生人一样交谈。
The sausage is good, she said. It's flavorful, but not too greasy. Not too greasy at all. Still though, it isn't dry. Neither are the biscuits, she said. They're light and crisp, very buttery. Very. These are some very buttery biscuits. They're flaky, but not too flaky. Not too flaky at all, she said.
“香肠不错，”她说。“有味，但不算太油腻。一点也不油腻。不过，也不干。”“饼干也是，”她说。“又轻又脆，非常香黄油味。非常香。这些饼干黄油味真浓。很酥，但没那么酥。一点也不酥，”她说。
We watched the path, awkwardly waiting for someone to release us from the torture of our stiff and meaningless conversation. I had always been afraid of sick people, and so had my mother. I think it was their fortitude that frightened us. Sick people reminded us not of what we had but of what we lacked. Everything we said sounded petty and insignificant. Our complaints paled in the face of theirs. And without our complaints there was nothing to say.
我们看着小路，尴尬地等待着有人把我们从这种僵硬、无意义的对话折磨中解救出来。我一直很害怕生病的人，我母亲也是。我想是他们的毅力吓到了我们。病人提醒我们的不是我们拥有什么，而是我们缺少什么。我们说的一切听起来都很琐碎、微不足道。我们的抱怨在他们的痛苦面前黯然失色。没有了抱怨，就没什么可说的了。
My mother and I had been fine over the telephone. But now, face to face, the rules had changed. If she were to complain, she risked being seen as a sick complainer, the worst kind of all. If I were to do it, I might come off sounding even more selfish than I actually was. This sudden turn of events had robbed us of our common language, leaving us to exchange the same innocuous pleasantries we'd always made fun of. I wanted to stop it, and so, I think, did she. But neither of us knew how.
母亲和我在电话里一直很好。但现在，面对面，规则改变了。如果她抱怨，她冒着被视为生病的抱怨者的风险，那是所有人里最糟的一种。如果我抱怨，我看起来可能比我实际还要自私。这一突发事件剥夺了我们的共同语言，让我们不得不交换那些我们一直以来嘲笑的平淡客套话。我想停止这一切，我想她也是。但我们谁都不知道该怎么做。
After the gifts had been opened, we returned to our rooms at the Econo Lodge, the reservations having been made by my father. We looked out the windows past the freeway and into the distance, squinting at the charming hotels huddled at the base of other finer mountains. This would be the last time our family was all together.
礼物拆开后，我们回到了伊克诺酒店的房间，预订是父亲做的。我们透过窗户望着高速公路，望着远方，眯着眼睛看着蜷缩在其他更高级山脉脚下那些迷人的旅馆。这将是我们家最后一次聚在一起。
It's so rare when one knowingly does something for the last time. The last time you take a bath. The last time you have sex or trim your toenails. If you knew you'd never do it again, it might be nice to really make a show of it. This would be it as far as my family was concerned. And it ticked me off that our final meeting would take place in such a sorry excuse for a hotel.
人们有意识地最后一次做某事是多么罕见。你最后一次洗澡。你最后一次做爱或修剪脚趾甲。如果你知道你再也不会做某事，能够好好展示一下可能也不错。就我们家而言，这就是终点了。而且让我火大的是，我们最后的聚会竟然发生在这种破酒店里。
What more do you want out of a hotel, he shouted, stepping out onto the patio in his underpants. It's clean. They've got a couple of snack machines in the lobby. The TVs work, and it's near the interstate. Who cares if you don't like the damn wallpaper? You know what your problem is, don't you? We're spoiled, we shouted in unison.
“你还想从酒店里得到什么？”他喊道，穿着内裤走到露台上。“它很干净。大堂里有几个零食机。电视能看，离州际公路又近。谁会在乎你喜不喜欢这该死的墙纸？”“你知道你的问题所在，对吧？”我们异口同声地喊，“我们被宠坏了。”
My parents retired to their room, and the rest of us hiked to a nearby cemetery, a once ideal spot that now afforded an excellent view of the newly-built Pizza Hut.
父母回到了他们的房间，我们其他人徒步去了附近的一个墓地，那曾经是个理想的地方，现在却能极好地俯瞰新建的必胜客。
Over the years, our mother had repeatedly voiced her desire to be cremated. We would drive past a small forest fire or observe the pillars of smoke rising from a neighbor's chimney, and she would crush her cigarette, saying, that's what I want right there. Do whatever you like with the remains. Sprinkle them into the ashtrays of a fine hotel. Give them to smart-ass children for Christmas. Hand them over to the Catholics to rub into their foreheads. Just make sure I'm cremated.
多年来，母亲一再表达她想要被火化的愿望。我们开车经过森林火灾，或观察邻居烟囱里升起的烟柱时，她会掐灭香烟，说道：那正是我想的那样。残骸想怎么处理都行。撒进高级酒店的烟灰缸里。圣诞节送给那些自作聪明的孩子们。交给天主教徒涂在额头上。只要确保我被火化就行。
Oh, Sharon, my father would groan. You don't know what you want. He'd say it as though he, himself, had been cremated several times in the past, but had finally wised up and accepted burial as the only sensible option.
“噢，莎伦，”父亲会呻吟道。“你不知道你想要什么。”他说得好像他自己过去曾被火化过几次，但终于变聪明了，接受土葬作为唯一的合理选择。
We laid our Econo Lodge bedspreads over the dewy grass of the cemetery, smoking joints and trying to imagine a life without our mother. If there was a heaven, we probably shouldn't expect to find her there. Neither did she deserve to roam the fiery tar pits of hell, surrounded for all eternity by the same [BLEEP] heads who brought  us strip malls and theme restaurants. There must exist some middle ground, a place where one was tortured on a daily basis but still allowed a few moments of pleasure, taken wherever they could find it. That place seemed to be Raleigh, North Carolina, so why the big fuss? Why couldn't she just stay where she was and not have cancer?
我们把伊克诺酒店的床罩铺在墓地潮湿的草地上，抽着大麻，试图想象一个没有母亲的生活。如果真有天堂，我们可能不该指望在那里找到她。她也不值得在那炽热的地狱焦油坑里徘徊，在永恒中被那些把商业街和主题餐厅带给我们的混蛋所包围。一定存在某种中间地带，一个每天都受折磨，但仍然允许享受片刻快乐的地方，随处可见。那个地方似乎就是北卡罗来纳州的罗利，那为什么要大惊小怪呢？她为什么不能待在原地，不患癌症呢？
Ever since arriving at the motor lodge, we'd gone back and forth from one room to another, holding secret meetings and exchanging private bits of information. We hoped that by preparing ourselves for the worst, we might be able to endure the inevitable with some degree of courage or grace. Anything we forecasted was puny compared to the future that awaited us. You can't brace yourself for famine if you've never known hunger. It is foolish even to try. The most you can do is eat up while you still can, stuffing yourself, shovelling it in with both hands and licking clean the plates, recalling every course in vivid detail.
自从到达汽车旅馆以来，我们不断往返于各个房间之间，召开秘密会议，交换私密信息。我们希望通过为最坏的情况做准备，我们能够以某种勇气或优雅来忍受不可避免的事情。我们预测的一切与等待我们的未来相比都是渺小的。如果你从不知道饥饿，你就无法为饥荒做准备。甚至尝试都是愚蠢的。你能做的最多就是在还能吃的时候吃，狼吞虎咽，双手并用，把盘子舔得干干净净，生动地回忆每一道菜的细节。
Our mother was back in her room and very much alive, probably watching a detective program on television. Maybe that was her light in the window, her figure stepping out into the patio to light a cigarette. We told ourselves she probably wanted to be left alone. That's how stoned we were.
母亲回到房间里，仍然活着，可能正在电视上看侦探节目。也许那就是窗户里的光，她那踏上露台点燃香烟的身影。我们告诉自己她可能想一个人待着。我们当时嗑得有多高。
We'd think of this later, each in our own separate way. I, myself, tend to dwell on the stupidity of pacing a cemetery while she sat, frightened and alone, staring at the tip of her cigarette and envisioning herself, clearly now, in ashes.
我们稍后会用各自不同的方式想起这件事。我自己，倾向于沉溺于那种在墓地徘徊的愚蠢，而她却独自坐在那，惊恐地盯着烟头，清晰地想象着自己灰飞烟灭。
David Sedaris. His story "Ashes" is in his book called Naked.
大卫·塞达里斯。他的故事《灰烬》收录在他名为《裸露》的书中。
My god, this is so boring.
天哪，这太无聊了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm still bowling on Fridays with the senior citizens.
我依然在周五和老年公民们打保龄球。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。